- All right everybody,
(audience cheering)
say hello to Tom Holland,
Jacob Batalon and Zendaya!
Give it up!
(audience cheers)
(soft music)
Well, Merry Christmas y'all.
I saw the movie last night,
it's insane. It is so good.
I just had to lead with
that. I was so excited.
I'm a Marvel fan.
It's one of my favorite
Marvel movies I've ever seen.
It was so good. Well done, but
Merry Christmas, everybody.
Who's got a holiday tradition.
They're looking forward to?
- My dad and I always liked
to drink a lot of port
at Christmas time.
He always buys these
like little taster boxes
of port and we go through
the day and we drink that.
So that's something I'm
excited to do with my dad.
- Wait, wait. He buys what?
- Port, like-
- Oh, port?
- I was wondering the same thing.
- I don't know why I'm doing this.
It's because it comes in a box.
- Oh, no I couldn't. It sounded poor.
I didn't know what you were saying. Port.
Your really cute accent,
I couldn't tell. Sorry.
Port. I was like, what?
Your dad does something with poor?
I was like, what? (laughs)
That's awesome. The little tiny ones.
That's awesome. I know
what you're talking about.
- Yeah, it comes in like
little taster boxes.
- Yeah, yeah. You gotta taste
'em all, all the flavors.
Well, Jacob, did you get Tom
and Zendaya Christmas gifts yet?
Did you get them gifts yet?
- Yeah?
- Yeah, Jacob?
- The funny thing is
we were supposed to be
on the show, but so sorry
we couldn't make it,
but I wanted to gift them
something from your show, Kelly.
I wanted to actually give
them the mugs that come
on your coffee table.
If that was possible.
- So Jacob, you are a re-gifter
is what we're saying here?
That's what we're saying here?
'Cause I was gonna give you mugs
and you're just gonna re-package 'em up
and re-gift them. (laughs)
- I thought it was an amazing
moment in our friendship,
because I think that being
on the Kelly Clarkson Show is amazing.
- [Tom] It is amazing. Very Exciting.
- So, you know, I think that
would have been a nice memento.
- Nice clean up.
- Yeah, well done.
- [Kelly] Jacob just stole my
gift to give you it's fine.
I will send you all mugs.
Did y'all get Jacob
anything? Just wondering.
I'm calling all of you out right now.
- We got him a lifetime of friendship-
(audience laughs)
And love.
- [Zendaya] And that should be enough.
- I knew it. Exactly.
Thank you.
- And, the number one movie in the year?
(all laugh)
- We actually, we wanted to get each other
like a commemorative gift
for like being in these movies.
We've done these movies together.
We've grown up together since
we were like 18 years old.
So, we wanted to get like
a Spider-Man themed...
- Right.
- Not a really holiday gift,
but like a special thing that we all had.
Like a friendship bracelet.
- Like a tattoo. Get a tattoo. (laughs)
That you will regret in years. (laughs)
He got a web. Y'all should all get a web.
- We've just been too busy
to go anywhere to buy it.
- Right.
- Yeah.
- Today is our last day of work together.
It's actually really sad.
- Oh my gosh.
- So maybe after this today
we can go and buy each
other a present.
- Yeah.
Maybe that's what we'll do
instead of you having a nap.
- And now it's a forced friend
gift brought to you by me.
You're welcome.
So what was it like to be a part
of just something so grand?
This is such a huge Marvel
movie. It's so good.
- I mean, I think I can
speak for all of us.
Even while we were making the movie,
we understood how
important this was to us,
and in turn how important
it was gonna be to the fans
of Spider-Man, and Marvel.
We'd walk on set
and certain things would
happen and we would shoot
certain scenes and you could
feel this kind of energy
on the set.
The crew as well were like
losing their minds in some
of the stuff that we were doing.
So, it did feel incredible
at the time and it feels
even more incredible now to be sharing
it with the world because
we've been sitting
on these secrets for two
years and honestly, like,
we're all so tired of lying.
- Also, it's just nice to be able to talk
about it with people.
- Yeah.
- You know?
- I know that's, I'm dying.
I don't wanna spoil it for anybody,
but I'm dying to tell everyone.
So, just literally go see
the movie so I can talk
about it, people.
So wait, Jacob, I have to ask you.
So you and Tom lived together
while working on the movie.
So, what's he like as a roommate?
Are y'all good roommates?
- Yeah. I feel like we're pretty good.
Yeah. We're like, it wasn't like.
It was a frat house in some ways,
but we weren't like trashing the place
and being like disrespectful.
I mean, sometimes. But
like, not all the time.
- It was a very sophisticated frat house.
- Okay.
- Absolutely.
- It was very grown up.
- This is the reason why I wasn't there.
- I love that you led that
answer with frat house.
You are my favorite, Jacob. (laughs)
You re-gift, you love frat
houses. I'm into Jacob.
Jacob, you're welcome any time here.
At 25, y'all, Zendaya has
already accomplished so much.
I'm such a big fan. I'm
so excited to meet a girl.
She's an executive producer, author,
the youngest person to win
an Emmy for outstanding lead actress.
(audience cheers)
So, I'm just saying I'm such a big fan.
I literally love everything you do.
You don't, you're not getting
your card that I wrote
you because y'all ended
up, you could come,
because I wrote you a card.
I was just such a big fan
of yours and I'm a fan
of y'all as well.
It's just look, I'm a
female, she's a female.
I'm like really into her. So anyway.
So anyway, my point is though, is like,
you've accomplished so
much, like so young.
Like, what else do you really wanna do?
Do you have like a list that
you're just checking off?
Like...
- Well, I just wanna say really quickly,
me and my mom love you,
and she wanted me specifically
to say hi to you from her.
So Mom, I'm saying, hi for you too.
- Yes, I am a hit with the moms.
- She's like, she's so
cool. Tell her I said hi.
- Oh my god, tell her I said what up?
- [Zendaya] Okay, okay, I will.
I there's so many things.
I mean, there's so many
things I would love to do,
and I think the most important thing,
and I think what I try
to keep in mind is I know
it's kind of a corny answer,
but it's like your
happiness and prioritizing
what makes you happy and brings
you joy, and inspires you.
And I think if you kind
of chase that feeling,
then you really can't go wrong.
So I always say like in the
future, will I be doing this?
I hope so because it's
what makes me happy now,
but maybe something else
will make me more happy.
Maybe there's other
things I wanna explore.
I love directing.
I was able to shadow John
this whole movie and watch
him work and be, and put
this incredible piece
of work together, which
was nearly impossible,
but, you know, every day
I'm learning and growing.
And I mean, there's so
many things I wanna do,
but as long as I feel
fulfilled and am doing things
for myself, I think that
that's the best way.
- Yeah. That's awesome.
(audience applauding)
That's literally like
what I tell everybody
that's starting like into the industry.
I'm like, don't chase it,
like chase what you want.
Like, chase your dreams.
That's so important and that's probably
why you're killing it.
So Zendaya, I actually
wanted to ask you this too.
So last year you said you have a heavy
responsibility in Hollywood.
So what does that mean to you?
I feel like we all have our own,
like everyone on the
couch there and myself,
anyone under the spotlight,
I feel like you have a
responsibility and ours are
all felt differently.
So what do you feel like yours is?
- I was talking about the
other day and I definitely
don't want to be, I don't
want people to want to be me
so much as through trying to
be the best version of myself,
help people along their journey,
trying to find the best
version of themselves.
- Yeah-
- Do you know what I mean?
And I think, yeah,
I think everyone's path is different.
Everyone's life is different and it's hard
to compare yourself to anyone else
because there's no other view.
You are the best version of who you are,
because there's no one else like you.
- Very true.
- And embracing that and
loving that about yourself.
that I feel like is my
job is in a lot of ways,
when I have an opportunity
to open opportunities
for others to make space for other people
who don't necessarily have the access
that I've been granted and
try to just do the best
I can to help someone
else do the best they can.
Do you know what I mean?
- Yeah, absolutely.
(audience applauding)
Absolutely.
You know what I wanna ask is,
I wanna ask this because
we all love you on film,
we all know you as actors,
we don't know as well.
So I wanna ask you all this,
like behind the scenes,
like Zendaya, like,
what's your favorite part
of working with like Tom or Jacob?
Like, what's the best
part of working with them?
- What's the best part of
working with these two clowns?
- Okay, buckle up, Jacob.
- I'm ready.
- No, I would say honestly,
anytime we were together,
we have so much fun together.
And that's not even just like
saying that just to say that.
Like, a lot of people say,
oh yeah, we laugh on set,
we have a good time.
Like we actually barely get work done.
(audience laughs)
Like I feel bad for John sometimes.
I do the best I can as the
mom of the group to like
keep us together.
but we just love each other
and we have so much fun.
- I think for me, it's
just our friendship.
how safe we feel on set.
When we're doing these films
and you're really on the
biggest stage the world
has to offer,
it's nice to be able
to do that with people
that you feel very comfortable with.
People that feel like family,
people that have your back, you know.
We really do do everything together
and we've lived together,
and we've made these movies,
we've traveled the world,
we've experienced things, our
lives have changed together.
So for me, it's our friendship
and the way that these,
this wouldn't have been
the same experience
without you guys.
And I hope I speak for
all of us when I say that.
Right, guys?
- Yes.
- I mean, sure, yes.
(Kelly laughs)
- Jacob...
Okay, wait, Jacob. I'm
gonna start with you, Jacob.
So be honest, after making
"Spider-Man", what do
you really do when you
see a spider in the room
in real life?
A, kill it? B, try to take it outside?
Or C, scream and have
someone else take care of it?
Jacob, go.
- So basically my girlfriend is really,
really not about hurting animals.
So I had to learn to like,
to just not be afraid
and scream like a little
girl and like try to pick
it up with a napkin and kind
of lead it out the window.
So I guess I do number two,
but inside I'm doing
number three all the time,
which is screaming like a little girl.
- I just simply love that I got you to say
I do number two and three sometimes.
(audience laughs)
Jacob, my God.
I love you. So, wait.
So, wait, Zendaya, what
do you do? Do you...
What do you do, A, B or C? Do you kill it?
Do you take it out or do you scream and go
somebody get that?
- I do D.
I just ignore it.
(audience laughs)
I just let it be.
- You ignore it.
- I'm just gonna leave it there.
Look away, you look back, It's gone.
It's not my problem any more.
(audience laughs)
- What if it crawls up on
you while you're sleeping?
- Well the difference is is
I live in England, so none
of the spiders in England can kill you.
You have spiders here that can kill you.
- Did you know spiders
can crawl into your mouth
when you sleep?
- It probably happens all the time, bro.
- Yes.
So you should definitely
get rid of the spider.
Maybe not kill it, but like get rid of it.
- I definitely take them
outside. I take them outside.
I don't like... I think
it's bad luck actually.
- Really?
- To kill one or to leave it outside?
- Yeah, if you find one
you have to kill it.
I don't kill bugs in my house.
I take them outside, just a general rule.
I try to convert people
to doing that as well.
- You are good like that.
I just see them as like little guests.
I'm like, welcome to the house, mate.
(audience laughs)
- Little guests.
- Can I get you anything?
- [Zendaya] Your house
is just bug infested?
- Yeah, I love it.
- But also, as Spider-man,
I feel like you cannot kill spiders.
- You know somewhere I always see spiders
and it's really weird?
In my car.
(Jacob laughs)
- They think it's a nice car.
- I'll be driving along. On the dashboard.
- Wait, I love that this angle,
you can see my socks and my sweatpants.
(audience laughs)
(audience applauding)
(Kelly laughs)
- My god, actually,
Zendaya, we couldn't see that at all here.
That is so awesome. (laughs)
I love Zoom.
Oh my God, that was me for
like a year on this show.
I literally had like a blouse,
and like yoga pants I didn't
do yoga in, and flip flops.
Like it was awesome. That was amazing.
Well, we need a break,
but 'cause there's no
segue for that awesomeness.
But first we've got an early
Christmas present courtesy
of our friends at IMAX.
Everyone in our audience
and house seats is getting
two tickets to see "Spider-Man:
No Way Home" in IMAX!
(audience cheering)
All right, y'all.
"Spider-Man: No Way
Home" is in theaters now.
Be sure to check it out.